nous accueillons donc le directeur
exécutif de l'agencé européenne de garde
frontières et de garde-côtes plus
communément connu sous le sigle frontex
nous avons partagé ensemble un petit
déjeuner chez le président il ya
quelques instants ce qui expliquait mon
retard personnel merci merci monsieur le
directeur exécutif d'avoir pris le temps
de venir rendre compte devant notre
commission de votre action à la tête de
frontex en dépit d'un agenda qui compte
tenu des circonstances
doit être particulièrement chargé
notamment à la frontière biélorusse et
nous aurons l'occasion d'en reparler
alors cette audition va nous permettre
de poursuivre les échanges que nous
avons eus moi mais un certain nombre de
nos collègues lorsque nous étions à
varsovie puisque je rappelle que le
siège de frontex et à varsovie
c'était au mois d été de le mois dernier
e mois de fans européens optent alors en
premier lieu cette audition va être pour
vous l'occasion de nous livrer un
éclairage sur le fonctionnement et
l'évolution de l'agencé frontex qui a
connu qui a connu de nombreuses
mutations depuis votre nomination en
lorsque vous avez pris les fonctions de
directeur exécutif en particulier
l'adoption du règlement de septembre
2016 à cet égard vous nous ferez un
bilan des principales innovations
prévues par ce règlement et en
particulier la mise en place d'un
officier aux droits fondamentaux au sein
de l' agence ou encore le mécanisme de
responsabilité partagée entre l'agencé
les états membres dans la protection des
frontières extérieures
dans le droit fil de cette réforme vous
pourrez aussi nous dresser un état des
lieux sur le déploiement du contingent
permanent de gardes frontières mise à la
disposition de l' agence et sur la
perspective d'atteindre l'objectif de 10
mille agents à votre disposition à
l'horizon 2027
puis j'espère que vous serez en mesure
de nous éclairer par des éléments
concrets sur la tacc hybride que l'union
européenne affronte actuellement à ses
frontières avec la biélorussie et sur le
soutien que frontex a apporté à la
lituanie et à la lettonie depuis le mois
de juillet dernier en déployant plus de
100 agents et en apportant à ces pays un
soutien logistique pour la fourniture de
voitures d'hélicoptères aux fins de
surveillance de frontières
le haut représentant politique
extérieure européenne monsieur borel a
estimé il y à une quinzaine de jours que
la situation était désormais sous
contrôle
la commission a annoncé que la pologne
avait sollicité l'aide de frontex qui
est assez nouveau puisque au départ il
ne voulait pas entendre parler pour
assurer le retour dans leur pays
d'origine des étrangers n'ayant pas
vocation à obtenir un titre de séjour et
donc sur ce point vous nous donnerez
votre analyse globale sur l'attitude de
l'union européenne et de ses
institutions au cours de cette crise
inédite qui a donné lieu à une
instrumentalisation sans précédent des
mouvements migratoires afin de
déstabiliser un certain nombre de nos
partenaires et du maire générale de
l'union dans son enfant vous nous dire
en particulier si frontex dispose
aujourd'hui des moyens adaptés tant sur
le plan matériel et financier bien sûr
que juridique et j'insiste sur ce point
car je crois qu'il ya un véritable
problème à ces dégâts
le contenu juridique de la mission afin
que vous puissiez justement exercer ses
missions pour la protection de nos
frontières extérieures vous nous direz
quelles leçons vous tirer de cette crise
et des instruments qui reste à mettre en
place pour être en mesure d'y répondre
puisque on sait bien que le souhait des
européens c'est qu'effectivement avoir
des frontières sécurisées enfin à
quelques semaines de la paix est furieux
de la présidence française de l'union
européenne on serait heureux de vous
entendre sur les différents projets de
réformes relatives à la protection des
frontières extérieures qui soit en
discussions soient en cours
d'élaboration
outre l'adaptation
temporaire des procédures de demande
d'asile aux frontières avec la
biélorussie qui était proposée par la
commission la semaine dernière le
gouvernement français ambitionne de
faire aboutir avant l'été prochain les
négociations relatives à la réforme du
code des frontières schengen vous nous
direz quels sont les principaux enjeux
de cette réforme et si elle est
susceptible d'avoir des conséquences sur
l'activité de frontex en matière de
protection de nos frontières extérieures
je vous rappelle que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo et qu'elle
est retransmise en direct sur le site du
sénat je vous propose selon les méthodes
la commission de vous exprimer pendant
une quinzaine de minutes si vous le
voulez bien un titre d'introduction puis
après un certain nombre de nos collègues
ils sont nombreux aujourd'hui
vous interrogeons sur telle ou telle
point ainsi que peut-être le président
rappaz qui est à mes côtés ce directeur
vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs tout
d'abord merci beaucoup de m'inviter ce
matin pour vous présenter la mise en
oeuvre du mandat de l'agencé frontex
agence européenne de garde frontières et
et de garde-côtes là les éléments
majeurs du nouveau mandat de l'agent ce
qui est entrée en vigueur en 2019 et la
constitution du corps européen de garde
frontières et de garde-côtes et
aujourd'hui en termes de déploiement
nous avons une force sur les sur le
terrain aux frontières extérieures de
l'union européenne et dans certains pays
voisins notamment dans les balkans comme
l'albanie la serbie et monténégro nous
avons au total entre 2000 et 2002 sans
personnel qui sont déployés à l'instant
où nous parlons nous avons plus de 200
véhicules terrestres qui sont déployés
dans le cadre de nos opérations soient
des véhicules de patrouille de
surveillance soit des véhicules pour le
transport des migrants nous avons
actuellement quatre hélicoptères engagés
ce sont des moyens qui sont mis à
disposition par les états est remboursé
par l' agence parce que nous n'avons pas
encore nos propres hélicoptères mais
nous avons dans le mandat de lagence
également le la mission de constituer
des capacités opérationnelles et
d'acquérir un certain nombre de moyens
de surveillance
nous avons 18 navires qui sont engagés
et nous avons déjà des avions notamment
si la possibilité d'avoir des avions de
l' agence qui sont loués à des
compagnies on y reviendra peut-être
ultérieurement
nous avons aujourd'hui en termes
d'opérations les plus grosses opérations
sont en grèce nous avons 450 personnels
nous avons en italie 200 personnels nous
avons un peu plus de 200 personnels en
espagne y compris les îles canaries et
nous avons évidemment en lituanie une
centaine de personnels qui ont été
déployés depuis le mois de juillet donc
en réponse à la menace hybride que vous
avez évoqué sur président et j'y
reviendrai nous avons
en réalité
effectivement une un mandat qui nous
permet d'offrir un appui c'est ça le
mandat de lagence d'appuie-tête
d'appuyer les états membres de l'union
européenne et de l'espace schengen à
faire du contrôle et de la surveillance
des frontières extérieures le mandat
porte sur la surveillance et mais aussi
je dirais on peut l'analyser en termes
de prévention de lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière qui est l'un
des phénomènes majeurs à nos frontières
extérieures de l'union européenne mais
il ya également un mandat qui est
orientée vers la lutte contre la
criminalité lutte contre la criminalité
sous toutes ses formes et pas uniquement
en lien avec l'immigration irrégulière
c'est peut être aussi lutte contre le
trafic de drogue aux frontières
extérieures
prévention des menaces terroristes et
puis en matière migratoire il ya aussi
le mandat de l'éloignement des étrangers
en situation irrégulière pour lesquels
nous avons des résultats opérationnels
de plus en plus important avec plus de
10% aujourd'hui des éloignements
effectifs de l'union européenne vers des
pays tiers qui réalisait avec le
concours et le soutien de l'agencé
frontex
nous avons dansé
dans ce corps européen aujourd'hui
effectivement l'objectif qui a été fixé
de 10000 personnel en 2027 et la
particularité et c'est ça la grande
nouveauté du mandat aujourd'hui c'est
que nous avons des agents un tiers du
personnel déployable et du personnel de
l'agencé pour la première fois nous
avons des agents publics de l'union
européenne portant l'uniforme européen
bleus qui a été dessiné pour pour cette
fonction qui ont le pouvoir d'utiliser
la force pour faire respecter
donc le code frontière schengen sous le
commandement tactique des états hôtes
puisque ce sont eux qui garde la
souveraineté mais dans le cadre d'un
plan opérationnel qui est agréé entre l'
agence et l'état hôte de nos de nos
opérations donc aujourd'hui nous mettons
en oeuvre
nous avons alors à peu près 650 agents
publics européens qui sont qui sont nos
propres agents 500 sont déjà déployés
sur le terrain 150 sens encore en
formation à l'école de police nationale
davila en espagne donc c'était avec
l'espagne pour une coopération pour cela
en ce moment et nous offrons donc ce que
nous appelons un catalogue de services
aux états membres donc qui couvre la
panoplie de tout ce qui est dans notre
dans notre mandat donc en réalité le
mode opérationnel va réduire de très
grandes opérations
tu as un caractère quasi permanent comme
poséidon en grèce indalo en espagne
temis en italie jusqu'à des activités
qui sont plus ponctuelle de plus petite
taille et qui peuvent être donc aussi
pour nous un moyen d'appuyer tous les
états membres je crois que ça c'est très
important de voir que l' agence avec le
corps européen n'est pas simplement une
espèce de système de secours de gestion
crise mais c'est un partenaire
opérationnel quotidien de l'ensemble des
tous les états membres de l'union
européenne une dimension importante
aussi
à noter c'est qu'en matière de lutte
contre la criminalité aux frontières
extérieures nous avons un mandat qui
nous permet de collecter des données
personnelles à des fins d'enquêtés
pénales donc nous ne conduisons pas les
enquêtes ce n'est pas notre mandat mais
notre mandat c'est de collecter
l'information les données personnelles
aux frontières extérieures lorsque nous
auditionnons des personnes
soit parce qu'ils sont entrés
irrégulièrement ou en tout cas au moment
du franchissement des frontières il il
ya une interaction et nous partageons
cela avec europol et nous sommes en
train de réviser notre notre cadre bon
ce sont des décisions internes prise par
le conseil d'administration
mais si tout à fait en phase avec notre
mandat pour échanger davantage avec les
services de police et d'en quête
nationaux dans les états membres et nous
avons aussi la possibilité de le faire
avec auront juste là c'est un axe
important pour ne pas simplement rester
sur un l'impression que c'est un mandat
migration mais qui s'est aussi un mandat
de lutte contre la criminalité aux
frontières nous avons un concept
opérationnel qui s'inscrit
dans un cadre
je dirais d'une d'une coordination plus
importante au niveau opérationnel la
gestion intégrée des frontières
extérieures ça veut dire non seulement
qu'il y a en application du mandat
l'ambition d'avoir une coordination de
la programmation on va dire des
investissements à réaliser de
l'acquisition d'un certain nombre de
capacités qui doivent être coordonnées
au niveau européen à la fois pour
équiper les forces nationales des états
membres mais aussi pour équiper les
agences et le corps européen qui vient
en soutien mais le concept opérationnel
de la gestion intégrée signifie aussi qu
à l'intérieur de chaque état membre
les différentes autorités nationales qui
contribue à la gestion des frontières
extérieures doivent avoir une
coopération plus souple quelques
exemples dans notre mandat il ya
évidemment une composante terrestre une
composante maritime nous avons aussi une
mission
de créer des fonctions de garde côtes au
niveau de l'union européenne en lien
très étroit avec l'agencé européenne de
contrôle des pêches et l'agencé
européenne de sûreté maritime et
évidemment tous les partenaires maritime
tous les garde côtes ou en tout cas les
forces nationales qui ont des moyens
maritimes nous avons une dimension
également de coopération avec les
douanes qui qui qui est également un
sujet stratégique
puisque les services douaniers si je
mets de côté la fonction fiscal qui
n'est absolument pas dans le mandat de
l'agent ce contexte mais tout ce qui a
trait à la sécurité à la lutte contre la
criminalité par exemple la lutte contre
le trafic de drogue il est évident que
des synergies avec les services
douaniers nationaux sont souhaitables
nécessaires et elles ont lieu et elles
ont lieu notamment également en france
mais pas seulement
il y a
ensuite bon comme dans notre catalogue
de services offerts aux états membres
nous sommes en train de de mieux faire
connaître les le mandat de lagence je
crois qu'il est il est très important
que le mandat de lagence soit connue
connu bien sûr par les services
opérationnels les états membres qui
peuvent faire appel à nous doit être
connue aussi me semble-t-il des
responsables politiques et je vous
remercie encore de l'invitation au sénat
en france parce que ça permet aussi de
rendre compte à la représentation
nationale
d'un certain nombre d'états membres
intéressés
ce que nous faisons parce que le mandat
de lagence le déploiement du corps
européen a un impact direct sur des
questions de sécurité et c'est une
compétence partagée entre l'union
européenne et des états membres alors il
y a évidemment une situation
particulière à la frontière entre la la
biélorussie d'un côté et
la
l'union européenne et plus précisément
la lituanie la pologne et la lituanie
qui souffre d'une menace hybrides alors
je sais pas je crois qu'on avait une
vidéo je sais pas si on peut la montre
et ou si
un jeu alors voilà en tout cas je peux
déjà commencé à parler en attendant que
peut-être le film soit disponible
en fait la la la
loukachenko a décidé de faire simplement
une affaire de chantage auprès de
l'union européenne mécontent des
sanctions de l'union européenne puisque
ce qui est à la clé c'est la non
reconnaissance de son élection
réélection à l'été dieu
[Musique]
en tout cas on a
on a des
opérations qui sont en tout cas pour
pour camper le paysage il y aurait entre
7000 et 15 mille migrants encore en
biélorussie dans la tente de franchir il
régulièrement la frontière pour entrer
soit en lituanie soit en pologne soit en
lettonie mais enfin c'est surtout la
pologne qui a été la lituanie qui sont
un abcès de fixation avec une
une une violence et une escalade de la
violence qui fait que
bon là la pologne n'a pas souhaité
avoir le la présence du corps européen
et de frontex physiquement à sa
frontière terrestre
bon je pense que la pologne a réussi à
déployer entre 25000 et maintenant je
crois près de 30000 personnel polonais
militaires et les gardes frontières
civile bon vous voyez qu'avec nos 2000 à
2200 personnel civil pour toute l'union
européenne nous ne faisons pas encore au
point
[Musique]
là là c'est une autre menace hybride
mais je crois que c'est intéressant si
les gardes côtes turques parce qu'il ya
eu aussi des menaces écrites de la part
de la turquie dès 2020
voyez les garde-côtes du rck qui sont en
train de harceler
et bien je crois que c'était un bâtiment
finlandais travaillant pour pour notre
pour l'opération poséidon en mairie j'ai
donc sont des manoeuvres qui ne sont pas
vraiment professionnel dans les règles
de l'art bon glace et la frontière s'est
vu de ce qui se passe que tu es et le
ruz on a des hommes en uniforme côté
biélorusse ce qui pousse des migrants
qui parfois ne sont pas non plus très
volontaires mais en tout cas qui sont
contraints
soit de traverser
lorsqu'il n'ya pas deux obstacles
physiques soit il ya des scènes on en a
vu là en pologne ces dernières semaines
avec des
délits véritable escalade avec
usage de la violence pour détruire
l'infrastructure construite par là par
la pologne
donc ce sont évidemment des
parts menace hybride on entend une
instrumentalisation quand même le voir
deux des migrants
comme moyen de pression politique ou
géopolitique
[Musique]
voilà donc c'est bien des finlandaises
correction bleu et blanc donc ce ne sont
pas des sont pas les grecs mais ce sont
les finlandais ce type d'incident a duré
à peu près une heure plus d'une heure
une heure et demie voilà donc on a eu
régulièrement au cours de l'année 2020
ce genre de comportement dans les eaux
territoriales grecques
donc donc tout ça pour dire que
aujourd'hui la question qui se pose
évidemment pour l'union européenne et
celle de la de la réponse mais pas
seulement opérationnelle
car vous vous voyez bien qu'on n'a pas
affaire à une immigration je dirais
irrégulière traditionnel naturel si si
si je puis dire ce que j'appelle par
naturel c'est lorsque vous avez une ride
et une route migratoire qui est le fruit
de la géographie qui est le fruit
évidemment de certains groupes criminels
de passeurs qui ont comme objectif de
faire de l'argent en exploitant la
misère humaine mais là on a affaire à
des instrumentalisations politiques
donc ça veut dire que la question est
politique et géopolitique
la turquie était déjà un bon exemple au
printemps 2020 lorsque le président
reagan annoncé que 150 mille migrants
allez pouvoir quitter la turquie est
entrée dans l'union européenne
principalement la grèce ça a mené un
sursaut évidemment côté de l'union
européenne une solidarité totale avec la
grèce et il a été demandé à frontex de
déployer en quelques jours une opération
rapide de gestion de crise que nous
avons fait mais l'exemple
finalement de la biélorussie
et l exemple parfait de la menace
hybrides parce qu'il n'y a aucune raison
naturelle d'avoir des ressortissants du
congo brazzaville en masse à minsk qui
ont pour seul objectif de prendre un
autocar pour aller à la frontière
lituanienne polonaise
donc ce que nous avons fait c'est à la
demande des autorités lituaniennes donc
une opération rapide qui a été lancé au
mois de juillet je pense que ça a été
l'occasion de montrer que le corps
européen fonctionne en l'espace de
quelques jours nous avons été capables
de déployer 140 personnels dans une
région de l'union européenne nous
n'avions aucune pratique à cette échelle
de déploiement avec une quarantaine de
véhicules donc de patrouille tous tout
tous ses véhicules au logo de l'union
européenne et de frontex donc ça a été
aussi une réponse permettant d'envoyer
un message de soutien
la lettonie a bénéficié aussi d'un
soutien
avec en nombre moins important un
déploiement du corps européen les
lituaniens les lettons pardon ont
préféré que nous soyons déployés à la
frontière russe et non pas la frontière
biélorusse car il considérait que la
frontière biélorusse était trop sensible
dans le cas de la malassise reid il
préférait que nous soyons la frontière
russe qui est une frontière qui
fonctionnent normalement bon normalement
contenu évidemment des restrictions
liées à la pandémie
la pologne a fait appel à nous pour
l'éloignement des étrangers en situation
irrégulière qui ont réussi à pénétrer
sur le territoire
polonais il y a
aujourd'hui un
nombre important d'irakiens les
autorités polonaises me disais au moins
1500 qui devrait être éloigné de la
pologne ce qui montre donc il ya eu il
ya eu des entrées quand même très très
importante il ya eu également des
mouvements dits secondaires
l'allemagne a observé dans les derniers
mois au moins 8000 personnes qui
seraient arrivés probablement de
biélorussie via la pologne où là où la
lituanie et qui ont fait des demandes
d'asile en allemagne donc nous avons
pour le moment
réussi à rapatrier
150 migrants de la lituanie vers les
pays d'origine notamment l'irak et nous
avons un nombre sensiblement égal qui a
été jusqu'à présent rapatrié avec le
concours de frontex de la pologne vers
l'irak comment ont réagi les autorités
de l'union européenne je dirais qu'il y
a eu un grand succès en ce qui concerne
une offensive diplomatique vers les pays
d'origine pour empêcher et pour
convaincre l'irak mais pas seulement un
certain nombre de pays de mieux
contrôler les départs et éviter donc que
les migrants puissent se rendre se
rendre à minsk donc de ce côté là je
pense que ça a été la démonstration que
quand l'union européenne parle d'une
voix avec détermination elle arriva à
convaincre sur la sur la scène
internationale je crois qu'en matière de
d'acceptation des rapatriements il y a
eu aussi évidemment notamment les
marches du vice-président skinn as qui
ont été très fructueuses après il ya
aussi une question qui est celle de
comment et tout y est juridiquement
l'union européenne par rapport à ce type
de phénomène vous avez vu les vidéos on
n'est pas dans une situation normale on
est dans des situations qui peuvent à
tout moment déraper vers la
confrontation militaire il ya eu des
face-à-face militaire chargement d'armes
tirant
avec des armes militaires tirent en
l'air mais bon entre la pologne et la
biélorussie on a eu aussi
entre la grèce et la turquie des
incidents pas aussi violent et pas aussi
sérieux que qu'avec la biélorussie mais
enfin c'est tout de même des
environnements où me semble utile
lorsqu'on est avec le corps européen on
peut être une cible politique on peut
être une cible physique mais on peut et
c'est peut-être ce qui vous intéresse
kiki qui nécessitent outils et l'union
européenne c'est que nous pouvons être
une cible politique et la question c'est
quand on est avec un corps européen en
uniforme européen avec des armes à feu
puisque dans quelques jours nous allons
pouvoir déployer aussi des armes à feu
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on est
physiquement à une frontière extérieure
qui est jeu politiquement sensible et là
moi je n'ai pas je n'ai pas la réponse
c'est une réponse politique géopolitique
et c'est pas le directeur d'une agence
opérationnelle qui doit répondre je
pense qu'il faut il faut prendre
conscience que nous arrivons avec des
éléments qui sont des éléments
embryonnaire mais d'une puissance et qui
est aussi une puissance opérationnelle
l'union européenne
il y a aussi des ambiguïtés juridique
qui ne sont pas résolus puisque
certaines
disons par exemple la loi lituanienne
qui était adoptée à l'été 2000 21 en
réponse aux menaces hybride la loi la
loi lituanienne dit que le
franchissement entre les points de
passage officiel et est interdite donc
ça c'est rigoureusement exact ça ne fait
que copier ce que dit le code frontière
schengen
et que si les personnes veulent demander
l'asile la protection internationale
elles doivent le faire dans les postes
frontières légaux qui continuent à
fonctionner en provenance de biélorussie
il y a
certaines voix qui qui interprète que ça
n'est pas légal que la loi lituanienne
serait en contradiction avec le droit
européen l'acquis de l'union européenne
en particulier les moniteurs de droits
fondamentaux puisque il y à il ya
aujourd'hui un officier des droits
fondamentaux qui est indépendant qui est
recruté par par l' agence frontex mais
qui est nommé par le conseil
d'administration et moi j'ai en tant que
directeur de l'agencé n'ai aucun pouvoir
ni sur l'officier des droits
fondamentaux ni sur les moniteurs de
droits fondamentaux qui sont aujourd'hui
une vingtaine et qui donc fondé rapport
en disant que la loi lituanienne n'est
pas conformes à l'ordre juridique
européen ce n'est pas mon rôle comme
directeur exécutif de l'agencé
interpréter la loi nationale pour dire
si elle est conforme oui ou non à
à l'ordre juridique de l'union
européenne je crois qu'il appartient à
la gardienne des traités qu'à la
commission européenne de répondre à
cette question mais ce qui est important
c'est la capacité de l'agencé à avoir un
cadre juridique clair et aujourd'hui je
considère que nous ne sommes pas en
sécurité juridique lorsqu'on vit et
travaille avec ce type d' ambiguïté
donc ça je crois que c'est très
important et vous voulez que ce qui me
frappe le plus au delà de la violence
qu'on voit sur les vidéos ce qui me
préoccupe davantage pour la durabilité
et la pérennité du déploiement du corps
bien la construction du corps européen
et pour l' agence c'est ces incertitudes
juridiques qui me préoccupe au moins
autant que la violence physique que nous
pouvons voir sur sur certaines vidéos
ensuite il ya des projets législatifs
effectivement en cours alors bon ce sont
des propositions delà de la commission
européenne donc je ne peux pas vraiment
les commenter il est évident qu'une
révision du code frontière schengen a un
impact sur le cadre de travail de
lagence peut-être en tout cas ce serait
utile vous l'avez compris de mon point
de vue que ces ambiguïtés juridique que
nous avons identifiées puisse être
clarifiée à l'occasion de certains
projets législatifs de l'union
européenne je terminerai peut-être mon
propos en vous parlant de la nouvelle
opération que nous avons en manche et
qui se déploie sur le territoire
français et belges suite à la réunion
donc
de calais avec le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur darmanin qui avait
invité la commissaire européenne du
rhône saône les ministres belges
néerlandais et allemand et avait ainsi
invité la directrice d'europol et et moi
même donc directeur de frontex donc ce
que j'ai proposé à son nom là ça
répondait à une demande de la france et
de la belgique c'est un accompagnement
par une surveillance aérienne l'avion de
frontex est arrivé à lille le 1er
décembre a commencé ses patrouilles donc
nous travaillons à améliorer
encore la diffusion peut être des images
vers différents centres opérationnels
nous avons déjà depuis quelques semaines
la fournit des images satellitaires nous
fournissons les images satellitaires à
la france la belgique s'est montré
intéressé avec les pays bas pour pouvoir
détecter quelques jours à l'avance des
préparatifs de départ et des activités
de passeurs ou de trafiquants près de la
côte nous pouvons faire davantage gelé
je les dis aussi si dans quelques
semaines il y a un souhait des autorités
françaises belges éventuellement
néerlandaise d'aller plus loin nous
pouvons non seulement utiliser notre
mandat en termes de rapatriement
éloignement les étrangers en situation
irrégulière nous avons un détachement du
corps européen à l'aéroport d'amsterdam
qui fait du soutien à l'éloignement vers
les pays tiers de l'union européenne
nous sommes en train de travailler que
la police aux frontières en france à
créer un
soudain détachement du corps européen à
roissy également avec les mêmes missions
nous avons la possibilité si la france
la belgique les pays-bas où l'un de ces
états
on fait la demande de déployer au sol
des personnels de garde frontières qui
pourraient avoir des missions de
surveillance
en complément des autorités nationales
est évidemment sous la direction
opérationnelle des autorités nationales
nous pouvons aussi contribué avec notre
mandat en matière de lutte contre la
criminalité je vous expliquais que nous
pouvons collecter des données
personnelles les mettre dans les bases
de données européennes l'aigle et les
partager avec les services des enquêtes
et donc
j'ai pu expliquer à calais comment nous
travaillons étroitement avec europol
selon une formule où nous partager avec
europol disons les gardes frontières et
les garde-côtes peuvent être les yeux
les oreilles de la police est en tout
cas c'est dans cet esprit que nous
travaillons évidemment une dimension de
secours en mer qui peut être un moment
se pose dans lors de la détection d'un
certain nombre d'incidents la mission
principale sur la côte française et
belge la mission principale de cet avion
est de détecter des départs mais bien
évidemment si des situations de détresse
en mer était observée en temps réel les
autorités compétentes seraient seraient
informés et quand je dis les autorités
compétentes ça veut dire en application
du droit international et on regarde où
la situation de détresse est observé et
sous quelle juridiction elle se trouve
et peut se trouver sous juridiction
française aux juridictions belges se
juridiction britannique ou néerlandaises
voilà je crois que je vais laisser place
aux questions aussi si vous le souhaitez
c'est le président merci monsieur le
directeur questions sont nombreuses je
vais d'abord donner la parole aux
présidents rapin dans la commission des
affaires européennes
merci monsieur le président cher
christian monsieur le directeur exécutif
d'abord
en tant que président de la commission
des affaires européennes vous apporter
un message de soutien parce que je sais
que votre mission n'est pas facile elle
n'est pas nouvelle elle est connue mais
elle sait elle s'exerce dans un contexte
de plus en plus de plus en plus tendue
vous agissez
opérationnellement sous l'égide des
états quand vous y êtes et avec un manga
européen
il ya un soutien politique partagée
d'ailleurs
par certains états membres et je
voudrais savoir aujourd'hui comment on
peut qualifier finalement le soutien des
institutions européennes à votre mandat
ça c'est ma première question mais je
réitère le soutien que vos avis je vous
apporte parce que poursuivre votre
mission depuis longtemps je sais qu'elle
est qu'elle qu'elle est complexe le
deuxième point concerne vos effectifs et
l'évolution de vos effectifs vous avez
parlé dix mille agents à l'horizon 2027
est ce que vous considérez aujourd'hui
que dans le suivi du calendrier on est
on est raccord avec une augmentation de
ses effectifs
en tout cas de deux sa prévision et je
suis convaincu qu'on regarde de la
situation internationale c'est
effectivement être moins plus que plus
que nécessaire
troisième point
vous êtes aujourd'hui observateurs et
acteurs à la frontière lituanienne
vous commencez à entrer dans le
dispositif polonais on est là sur sur
une frontière où les tensions sont
importantes avec un hiver qui arrive
rapidement pouvez vous nous dire si vous
craignez ou non une crise humanitaire
sur ces signes parce que je pense que
c'est très important de l'anticiper de
l'envisager
parce qu'il ne faudrait pas que nous
subissions
ce qu'il a subi ronces et ceux qui vont
la vivre mais que nous subissions en
europe et quand je parle d'europe je
parle de la politique européenne
finalement les retours négatifs de ceux
qui ont créé cette situation et profiter
de fractures un petit peu plus nos
démocraties si jamais il y avait des
drames comme il ya pu y en avoir en
manche et dernier point vous avez évoqué
la question de la manche je devais le
faire en particulier en tant que tant
que sénateur du pas de calais mais je ne
vais pas m'exprimer en tant que sénateur
du pas de calais je m'exprime est en
fait en observateur de tout ce qui se
passe sur la côte sur le littoral de la
manche puisque aujourd'hui le phénomène
nous en avons discuté avant mais moi je
le jeu le distille depuis un certain
temps puisque je contacte à la fois les
préfet mais aussi les élus du de ce
littoral là on sait que le phénomène
peut s'étendre jusqu'à la bretagne
aujourd'hui avec des traversées qui ne
vont pas directement vers le royaume uni
mais dont on sait qu'elles vont se faire
vers l'irlande
et vous savez derrière la conséquence
qui pourrait y avoir de ça c'est à la
demande du royaume uni la recréation du
les frontières entre l'eire et l'irlande
du nord donc je pense que ce sont des
phénomènes qui sont réellement
anticipées il ne faut pas les négliger
parce que on sait très bien que dans le
temps certains phénomènes se sont
produits qu'on n'attendait pas et celui
ci pourrait en faire pourrait en faire
partie donc voilà les les points
particuliers et un dernier auquel
j'ajouterai
suite aux discussions qu'on a pu avoir
chen président ce matin c'est de savoir
l'organisation que vous pouvez avoir sur
les avec les administrations et là je
parle que de la france avec les
administrations que ce soit les
administrations maritimes
et national de sécurité bien sûr
je pense à la mise en place du
dispositif
avionique sur le sur le littoral alors
que l'on sait très bien qu'on bénéficie
déjà de moyens importants donc votre ça
rend votre tâche plus difficile de
l'interconnexion entre les différents
services mais je voudrais savoir comment
ça se passe merci voilà je vous
proposerai pour tout de suite au
président puis après on va prendre les
différentes questions je rappelle que
nous avons l'audition de nicolas de
lacoste après inquiets l'ex futur
ambassadeur en biélorussie puisqu'il n'a
pas été accrédités et qu'il est
maintenant considéré comme envoyé
spécial pour la biélorussie qui
complétera et j'imagine votre propos ce
directeur
merci monsieur le président le soutien
des institutions de l'union européenne
il est
bon évidemment lille il ya la commission
qui est qui joue le rôle de on va dire
de demander le budget pour l' agence de
frontex vis-à-vis des autorités
budgétaires de l'union européenne que
sont le conseil et le parlement nous
avons bon une
une relation fluide avec la commission
européenne
sur un certain nombre de questions liées
au déploiement c'est vrai que sur les
questions juridiques je suis en attente
je comprends que la question n'est
peut-être pas que juridique mais qu'elle
est peut-être aussi politique
et donc je pense que nous avons un peu
tout ça à prendre maintenant à
fonctionner avec l'existence d'un accord
européen qui donne des responsabilités
nouvelles je le vois au niveau d'une
agence nous devons organiser la
logistique nous devons organiser le
déroulement de carrière le recrutement
de nos agents ce sont des rôles et des
missions nouvelles et je crois que
chaque institution et ça vaut aussi pour
les autorités nationales
tout le monde se découvre
peut-être chemin faisant un nouveau rôle
parce que ce qu'un européen ne met pas
seulement des responsabilités sur l'
agence mais aussi sur tous les acteurs
je crois que le conseil les relations
avec le conseil bon sens ont sondé
relation fluide aussi
nous travaillons pour les états
nous travaillons étroitement avec les
états sous le commandement des états
donc je crois que le conseil de l'union
européenne a un intérêt de plus en plus
important
vis-à-vis du déploiement du corps
européen
le parlement européen joue son rôle de
parlement et donc de contrôle
démocratique avec parfois bon une
polarisation de plus en plus marquées
sur ces sujets
avec des parlementaires européens qui
sont vraiment d'un très grand soutien et
puis d'autres parce que ce sont leurs
options
qui sont tout à fait légitime en
démocratie mais qui ne souhaite pas
qu'il y a un corps européen et ne
souhaite pas qu'on contrôler les
frontières
ensuite en terme de ressources alors ça
doit se voir dans le cadre du dans le
cadre financier pluriannuel de l'union
européenne de 2021 jusqu'à 2027 il faut
savoir que par rapport aux propositions
qui avaient été faites par la commission
européenne en 2018 donc avant les
élections européennes
il y a aujourd'hui un budget réduit de
40% pour l' agence ça veut dire
clairement que il est difficile alors
que l'ambition de dix mille
dix mille membres du corps européen n'a
pas été réduite à la baisse donc
ça va pas être sur les salaires et les
coûts du déploiement qu'on va pouvoir
économiser et malheureusement ça veut
dire que ça ampute la capacité
d'investissement terre de construction
d'une capacité avec des moyens autonomes
on a vu par exemple à l'occasion de la
surveillance aérienne que que nous
pouvons fournir le voyons avec les
véhicules les deux de patrouille que
nous avons pu envoyer en quelques jours
même en quelques heures en lituanie
depuis varsovie
que c'est utile d'avoir cette
flexibilité
il ya aussi la question des
investissements qui nécessiteront des
budgets importants pour la
digitalisation du métier des contrôles
aux frontières
il ya le système entrées/sorties qui
arrivent il ya le système ethias et
toute une modernisation du travail des
garde-frontières dans lequel l' agence
frontex peut jouer un rôle à un mandat
moteur pour accompagner l'ensemble des
services nationaux en tout cas ceux qui
en font la demande donc je pense qu'il
faut voir que la question budgétaire
reste reste une épée de damoclès
jusqu'en jusqu'en 2027 la question des
effectifs
il y a eu l'âge ans a perdu en 2019 mais
c'était après après l'été 2010 neuf et
ça ne m'a été vraiment confirmé je
dirais gravé dans le marbre que qu'au
printemps 2020 nous avons perdu une
centaine de postes enfin qui ont été
transformés dans des grades inférieurs
mais là
la conséquence concrète c'est
qu'aujourd'hui je ne peux pas recruter
autant qu'il le faudrait les chefs
d'equipe qui accompagne le camp européen
donc la colonne vertébrale de
l'encadrement de proximité du corps
européen opérationnelle sur le terrain
ne veut pas être recruté correctement
sans parler des difficultés à recruter
au siège puisque nous avons une
structure qui a grandi nous sommes
censés avoir un corps européen à 10000
nous avons aujourd'hui déjà
2200 personnel sur le terrain ça
s'accompagne nécessairement de structure
support et de service soutient qu'ils
doivent être au siège ou dans un certain
nombre d'antennes régionales que nous
allons créer donc sur les effectifs j'ai
enfin sur la dgrad qui sont qui sont
données j'ai effectivement une
difficulté importante et je fait écho
aussi aux difficultés qui me sont
remontés par les directeurs des
différents services de l'agent ce qu'ils
font état
une grande fatigue du personnel qui ne
peut plus prendre ses congés parce
qu'ils sont obligés de faire le travail
de une feinte de deux ou trois personnes
dans des conditions qui sont celles que
nous avons une pression très forte pour
déployer rapidement la pandémie qui
quand même un peu partout en europe se
fait sentir parce que les choses vont un
peu moins vite ils sont un peu plus
compliqué donc donc moi je suis
préoccupé de ne pas pouvoir recruter au
bon grad sur un certain nombre de
fonctions ensuite sur les le phénomène
en manche alors effectivement à partir
du moment où on commence à sécuriser de
façon très forte une partie du littoral
ou une partie d'une frontière les
phénomènes de franchissement irrégulier
et ont tendance à se
déplacer vers d'autres vers d'autres
endroits les autorités belges qui il ya
quelques mois encore se pensait
peut-être un peu moins concernés
aujourd'hui
se sentent concernés et on fait si je
puis dire front commun avec la france
pour demander l'appui l'appui de frontex
les autorités néerlandaises se sont
montrés très intéressés depuis un
certain temps et me disent qu
effectivement il commence à observer des
phénomènes douteux avec des bateaux de
plaisance dans certains ports
néerlandais est donc
donc si les choses se déplace vers le
nord et que nous y compris jusqu'aux
pays bas et que nous nous prenons les
bonnes mesures elles vont se déplacer
aussi vers l'ouest avec comme vous
l'indiquez ce sénateur la république
d'irlande qui peut être notamment par le
biais de liaisons ferry donc ce que ce
qui peut être fait c'est un renforcement
des contrôles sur les embarquements au
moment des ferries c'est un peu par
analogie avec ce qui se fait déjà à
calais
si il y à des phénomènes qui se confirme
à la république d'irlande effectivement
il y aura un souci en tout cas les
britain le royaume uni aura un souci sur
sa frontière avec la république
d'irlande et voilà il ya une zone de
libre circulation entre les deux états
c'est important pour les dames en la
stabilité de l'irlande et la paix
voilà ce sont ce sont effectivement des
scénarios que je ne peux pas écarté et
peut-être sur l'organisation avec les
administrations françaises nous avons
une relation très fluide avec tous les
services du ministère de l'intérieur
également avec la marine nationale et
les services des douanes donc de ce
point de vue là nous avons un plan
opérationnel qui a été adoptée en une
journée avec les autorités françaises
mais aussi avec les autorités belges ce
qui nous a permis de déployer l'avion
avec un mandat opérationnel et
ce sont les autorités nationales qui ont
le commandement tactique
chacun dans sa compétence chacune dans
sa compétence nationale et les relations
sont très fluides donc je suis
extrêmement satisfait
alors danger de crise humanitaire il
existe il existe et c'est précisément
l'objectif d'une menace hybrides parce
que c'est pour avoir des images
terribles et une réalité terrible avec
des personnes qui meurent il ya déjà eu
je crois au moins une dizaine de morts à
la frontière entre la pologne et la
biélorussie bon côté biélorusse côté
parfois polonais
moi je note que c'est assez intéressant
il ya eu des décisions de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme à la
fois vis-à-vis de la lituanie et
vis-à-vis de la pologne
et ce sont des décisions d'urgence
temporaire mais d'urgence qui ont été
prises par la cour européenne des droits
de l'homme qui dit en substance
il y a un devoir d'humanité qu'il y a un
devoir d'apporter une aide humanitaire
de la nourriture bon une protection
contre le froid mais chaque état a le
droit de décider qui entre ou non sur
son territoire et donc l'injonction qui
a été fait à la lituanie ou à la pologne
c'était de pourvoir aux côtés caractère
humanitaire mais sans en joindre à la
pologne ou à l'actu ni d'accepter ces
personnes sur le territoire après
affronté que ce n'est pas une agence
humanitaire mais je déplore évidemment
la mort de personne la mise en danger je
crois que ça montre une fois de plus que
les migrants sont des victimes et qui a
intérêt à communiquer très largement
pour mettre en garde les migrants contre
ce type de menace n'est pas seulement la
menace des groupes criminels et des
passeurs mais il ya aussi des menaces
hybride géopolitique
merci je dirais alors maintenant on va
passer aux 13 13 demandes d'intervention
donc je demande à chacun de concentrer
sa pensée on va pendant les quatre
premières cédric perrin
merci monsieur le président monsieur
directeur très rapidement parce que
l'essentiel des questions quelques
auquel j'avais pensé non été on a eu des
réponses que je vais revenir rapidement
il ya quelques années au moment où
l'amiral bléjean commandés
frontex et sofia j'étais intervenu dans
ses passes ont cette salle mais pas très
loin d'ici en dix ans de manière assez
provocatrice que font tes que c'était
surtout une opération de séduction de
rescue et qu'on avait ressuscité la sncm
une agence de transport pour migrants
c'était très dur mais c'était en 2015 en
tout cas l'opinion que j'avais
aujourd'hui on a après un rapport qu'on
a fait sur la libye ici dans cette
commission il ya trois ans maintenant
avec un certain nombre de mes collègues
on avait surtout soulevé un certain
nombre de points est ce que vous pouvez
nous donner quelques éléments sur
l'attitude de la libye il y avait la
problématique de la formation et du
financement des garde-côtes et la
possibilité qu'il y avait pour frontex
d'approcher les le territoire libyen
faute d'état
en place qui autoriserait la possibilité
d'aller détruire les embarcations des
passeurs en libye directement pour
mettre un terme à un certain nombre de
passages est-ce que vous pouvez juste
nous donner quelques informations sur
l'état de cette cible de la situation
aujourd'hui merci merci cédric olivier
cigolotti vous répondre et
collectivement une manière précise merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
directeur vous l'avez évoqué dans votre
propos liminaire un certain nombre de
grands états se montre assez réticents à
faire appel à frontex tu affrontes ex
pardon pour un certain nombre on a le
sentiment que ça revient à avouer le
fait qu'ils ne sont pas en capacité de
surveiller et d'assurer le contrôle à la
frontière le président a évoqué à titre
d'exemple seule la lituanie et la
lettonie ont fait appel à frontex alors
que la pologne malgré l'insistance de
bruxelles a refusé dans un premier temps
comment est-ce que vous analysez ce
paradoxe alors que les 27 états membres
ont fait le choix ensemble de muscles et
frontex et vous aurez vous avez rappelé
le le montant du budget pour de la
période 2021 et 2027 qui dépassera les 5
milliard d'euros est ce que vous pensez
qu'il ya vraiment une réelle
problématique pour certains états de
faire appel à frontex merci merci
olivier jacques le nay le président sur
directeur vous avez récemment déclaré
que l'union européenne doit se préparer
à d'autres crises migratoires comment
l'agent son texte si prépare-t-elle avez
vous les moyens de faire face à
plusieurs grandes crises
migrateurs en même temps et puis sur le
problème de la manche existe-t-il des
discussions avec le royaume uni pour
rétablir un accord autorisant votre
élection sur le territoire britannique
merci philippe folliot
oui merci monsieur le président ce
directeur exécutif tout d'abord c'est un
honneur d'avoir un français qui vit
président une agence internationale
comme common frontex ensuite je voulais
vous attire votre attention sur un
élément et vous poser une question le
point ses surnoms départements
d'outre-mer je pense notamment à mayotte
et en guyane qui sont hors
donc schengen mais savoir si il peut y
avoir des éléments spécifiques
d'accompagnement parce que la situation
est réellement insupportable dans ces
deux territoires en termes de nombre de
clandestins qu'il peut y avoir promené à
la population donc est-ce que vous
pouvez avoir une aide apportée à la
france en la matière ensuite vous avez
vous avez parlé de la réserve de
réaction rapide de 1500 personnel quel
est le statut et quelle nationalité
qu'aux composent cette réserve de
réaction rapide en fait de manière plus
globale de commandes peut-il à votre
mandat pour être pleinement efficace et
répondre aux états membres
ce directeur si vous pouvez faire donc
une réponse à ses quatre premières
interventions
alors contraire merci monsieur le
président concernant la libye
le frontex n'a pas le mandat
d'intervenir en libye mais il y à la
démission de la politique de défense et
de sécurité commune dont notamment
l'opération militaire irini de l'union
européenne chi chi chi à ce mandat nous
travaillons en coopération
aujourd'hui entre entre irigny et
frontex sur l'analyse des risques sur
éviter les
l'explication de moyens qui sont qui
sont sur zone pour bien coordonner des
cons pour yves jeu que les ministères en
français dès des conflits ctions des
déploiements et puis nous pouvons
travailler ensemble sur la construction
de capacités alors aujourd'hui il y
avait il ya moins je crois qu'il n'y a
plus de formation de gardes frontières
libyens ça a été un petit peu suspendue
néanmoins il y a eu à des
investissements importants financé par
l'union européenne 46 millions pour
créer le centre de secours maritimes de
tripoli qui répond de plus en plus
avec dans des sauvetages qui sont
réalisés par les garde-côtes libyens
c'est une question qui est souvent
controversées par certaines ong en
particulier qui considère que le secours
en mer même lorsqu'il a lieu dans la
zone de secours en mer libyennes déclaré
internationalement devrait avoir pour
effet que les migrants soient conduits
en europe
bon le droit international dit que c'est
le centre de secours maritimes
territorialement compétent qui doit agir
qui doit être informée et lorsque nous
avons par nos moyens aériens comme le
drone mâle que nous déployons en mini
centrale ou dans un an nous avions nous
détectons des cas de détresse en mer
mais devons partager l'information en
temps réel nous le faisons
systématiquement avec l'italie et malte
même quand ce sont des cas qui sont
proches de la libye mais lorsque ce sont
dans les eaux ou dans les zones sous
compétence libyenne ou tunisienne de
secours en mer nous sommes obligés par
leur international de prévenir
respectivement tripoli ou tunis
des états hésitent à a demandé l'appui
de frontex moi je crois qu'il ya
peut-être deux de type d'explications
une explication qui était un peu
traditionnelle effectivement c'est que
ça donnait un peu le sentiment ou
certains peut avoir le sentiment d'un
aveu de faiblesse d'un aveu d'échec d'un
capacité à régler soi même sur le plan
national
je crois que ça on y travaille en disant
ce n'est pas une honte d'avoir frontex
au contraire elle corps au ps ça doit
être une fierté et vous devez d'ailleurs
demander votre part du service puisque
c'est la démarche que nous faisons il ya
un catalogue de services vous financez
en contribuant au budget de l'union
européenne tous les états financent
vous faites un effort en mettant à
disposition des personnels donc vous
avez un retour qui est légitime et donc
servez-vous dans le catalogue des
services et voyez ce que nous pouvons
faire pour vous je crois que la démarche
commencez à bien embrayer et je voudrais
donner l'exemple de la finlande qui
cette semaine nous permet de déployer et
c'est un peu un projet pilote à la
frontière russe au poste frontière
mais aussi pour patrouiller et nous
allons pouvoir d utiliser des armes
finlandaise mise à disposition du corps
européen pour patrouiller la frontière
russe donc c'était un état qui pouvait
avoir initialement le sentiment que tout
ça c'était plutôt pour le sud et voilà
qu'il nous permet de venir en finlande
donc je trouve que c'est intéressant et
notre d'hésitation de certains états
alors la pologne c'est quand même parce
qu'il a un niveau de violence est là on
est quasiment dans une une confrontation
militaire je ne suis pas certain que
nous soyons outils et opérationnellement
est aussi politiquement parce que
qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on est en
uniforme européen est qu'il ya une
situation qui proche d'un d'une escalade
militaire on fait quoi qui nous donne
quelques consignes donc là on n'est pas
outillée
et je pense qu'il ya peut-être aussi et
là c'est peut-être plus plus sérieux
encore c'est ce sont ces interrogations
juridiques on voit que la lituanie est
accusé par certains de violer les droits
de l'homme
des voix me demande mon demandé
d'arrêter les opérations lituanie au
motif que la loi lituanienne ne seraient
pas conformes à l'ordre juridique on
perd alors que personne aujourd'hui
aucune source autorisée en tout cas ne
me confirme que ce soit illégale ou
légal donc je pense que d'autres états
observent ils se disent que donc certain
nombre de questions ne sont pas
clarifiées juridiquement ils n'ont pas
trop envie de se retrouver sous le feu
des projecteurs accusé de violer les
droits de l'homme alors qu'en fait il
ils contrôlent la frontière conformément
peut-être en tout cas à la
réinterprétation du code frontière
schengen
d'autres crises migratoires se prépare
et oui mais je crois qu'il faut avoir
conscience que nous allons vivre pour
longtemps avec une pression migratoire
extrêmement forte la démographie l'exil
explique
les déséquilibres économiques
l'expliquent accentuer encore par les
conséquences de la pandémie si on voit
les conséquences économiques sur le
maghreb bon qui font qu'aujourd'hui on a
un nombre plus important pour ne donner
qu'un exemple à un nombre plus important
de migrants économiques en provenance du
maroc en provenance de la tunisie en
provenance de l'algérie même si je dois
dire que le maroc est un excellent
partenaire et tient bien dans la
coopération avec l'union européenne et
l'espagne mais on voit bien que les flux
se déporte un peu plus sur la
méditerranée centrale parce que
justement le maroc joue un rôle
important dans la surveillance donc nous
nous y préparons par des en construisant
la capacité du corps européen il faut
être flexible je crois que nous l'avons
démontré en déployant quelques jours
vers la lituanie en déployant en
quelques jours faire vers la france donc
je crois que c'est ça qu'il faut
continuer et il faut également anticiper
en ayant des capacités de gestion des
frontières bien
coordonnée dans les investissements et
l'inter opérabilité opérationnel au
niveau
européen avec le royaume uni il n'y a
pas aujourd'hui d'accord entre l'union
européenne et le royaume uni pause par
exit pour coopérer pour éventuellement
permettre à frontex de travailler en
coopération avec le royaume-uni dans la
manche avec éventuellement une présence
physique si cela était souhaitée
donc vous voyez le paradoxe nous sommes
présents physiquement en albanie nous
sommes présents physiquement serbie au
monténégro parce qu'il ya un accord
entre l'union européenne et ces pays là
mais il y en a pas avec le royaume uni
moi j'ai exprimé
l'intérêt de pouvoir travailler bien sûr
mais dans le cadre juridique il s'agit
pas de faire du cas par cas informel on
est là sur des matières sérieuses et on
ne peut travailler que dans le cadre
d'un app d'un accord qui serait
probablement un accord de plein droit
international et ratifié on peut pas
faire du bricolage à la carte
de façon informelle en disant c'est pas
grave on s'arrange comme ça dont on doit
on doit être très sérieux dans ce que
l'on fait
pour ce qui est
de l'outre-mer français
alors il a des statuts juridiques un peu
variable par rapport à redire à
l'intégration dans l'union européenne ou
non
et on peut bon nous avons regardé un
petit peu affronter parce que cette
question nous est régulièrement posée
on peut probablement
envisagées en matière d'éloignement des
étrangers en situation irrégulière une
compétence une possibilité d'aider
puisqu'il n'y a pas de référence à
schengen mais là où il faut là où notre
compétence est déterminée par le fait
que c'est une matière schengen lorsque
ce sont des territoires et départements
d'outre-mer qui sont hors schengen et
c'est le cas de tous
et bien là nous ne pouvons pas envisager
je pense un déploiement physique mais
nous pouvons peut-être envisager des
coopérations en matière de développement
des capacités de conseil à voir en tout
cas nous sommes nous sommes
ouverts à un dialogue avec les autorités
françaises sur ce point la
réaction rapide quels sont les
nationalités alors dans le corps
européen en fait nous avons aujourd'hui
des agents nationaux qui sont mis à
disposition par les états membres qui
remplissent des quotas obligatoires donc
il y a dans le règlement européen un
nombre précis par état membre disant tel
état membre doit fournir tel nombre de
deux garde-frontières ça c'est pour les
catégories d'aidés disons ça représente
les deux tiers qui viennent des états
membres pour ce qui est de nos propres
employés qui sont des agents publics
européens ils ne sont pas recrutés sur
un critère de nationalité le seul
critère c'est qu'il faut être
ressortissant de l'union européenne ou
d'un espace schengen associés comme la
suisse ou la norvège par exemple et là
nous avons un déséquilibre géographique
énorme puisque près de la moitié de nos
employés qui sont dans le corps européen
sont
romain ou grecque donc là
directement ça a un impact enfin c'est
l'impact du niveau des salaires c'est
l'impact du fait que nous avons un
coefficient correcteur parce que
l'agencé basée à varsovie donc le
salaire des employés y compris le mien
comme tout le monde et 70% du salaire
théorique fixée à bruxelles donc ans
quand le l'autorité budgétaire
européenne fixe un salaire à 100 il faut
savoir que quand on est à varsovie on
est à 70 quand on est en bulgarie on est
à 48
quand on est
en suède on est à 120 ou 130 voilà mais
ça a un impact ça veut dire que pour
certaines nationalités il n'est pas
intéressant d'être candidat parce que
financièrement ce n'est pas possible
donc donc donc voilà ça ça fait
peut-être un peu écho aussi à al ala
question sur les ressources et je trouve
que c'est préoccupant parce que si on
veut que le corps européen soit vraiment
européen il faut qu'ils représentent la
diversité géographique de toutes les
nationalités parce que sinon on aura une
difficulté y compris une difficultés
opérationnelles je ne veux pas déployé
des agents opérationnels dans leur
propre état membre donc je ne veux pas
déployer des grecs en grèce je veux les
déployer ailleurs mais si à un moment
donné
la moitié du corps européen de nos
effectifs vient d'un état membre et que
c'est un état membre qui a besoin de
secours européen ça pose une difficulté
opérationnel mais pas seulement sur la
diversité culturelle merci monsieur
directeur nous allons prendre quatre
intervenants suivants isabelle raymond
pas verrou
suite à l'événement qui s'est passé donc
dernièrement au niveau de la manche 1 le
ministre de l'intérieur
annoncé le déploiement d'un avion
frontex au dessus de la manche alors si
ce dispositif permet indéniablement de
renforcer la lutte contre le trafic
migratoires le gouvernement a rappelé
qu'en la matière il était nécessaire
qu'un accord puisse intervenir entre lui
et le royaume uni et qu'il soit établi
aujourd'hui les relations diplomatiques
avec nos amis britanniques doivent se
renforcer
considérez vous comme nécessaire quelles
sont les dispositions que vous
considériez comme nécessaire aujourd'hui
à la mise en place de cette coopération
migratoire efficace entre l'union
européenne et le royaume uni merci merci
isabelle abdallah hassan i
et s'est absenté alors marié arlette
carlotti oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le directeur exécutif vous avez
largement développé la crise migratoire
dans des secteurs qui font l'actualité
une actualité dramatique que ce soit la
manche le front de la pologne et puis
maintenant vous parliez de la frontière
belge permettez moi de moi de cibler ma
question sur la question de la
méditerranée puisque l'année 2000 21
aura été l'une des années les plus
meurtrières depuis ces trois dernières
années avec 1300 personnes mort dans la
méditerranée ou entre nous on se baigne
régulièrement sous un soleil formidable
donc c'est vraiment une grosse
difficulté pour moi d'entendre ça vous
avez déployé beaucoup d'opérations dans
ce secteur certaines date de 2015 elles
sont vous le disiez tout à l'heure
permanente donc vous avez le recul pour
ou dire qu'est ce que vous pouvez tirer
comme leçon précisément j'aimerais
savoir si ça a progressé en matière de
lutte contre les contre forts toute
forme de de voyeurisme de voyeurisme
fanny voyoucratie les passeurs mais
aussi la question de la drogue parce que
je crois que vous savez que la micra qui
est une zone de grande fracture et ils
se posent des problèmes et surtout je
voudrais vous interroger sur comment
vous concilier la sécurité des
frontières et la question du sauvetage
des migrants c'est à dire que vous
disiez tout à l'heure nous ne sommes pas
une agence humanitaire c'est vrai mais
il ya quand même une possibilité de
négocier les deux de concilier les deux
vous disiez d'ailleurs que vous étiez
pour une approche intégrée de frontex et
vous savez que les parlementaires
européens ne sont pas totalement
d'accord avec vous puisqu'ils nous ont
aussi déclaré souvent que quand vous
parlez de éloignement et ça voulait dire
des retours à la frontière extrêmement
muscles et viril ces jeux pas si c'est
le mot mais en tout cas c'est celui que
son employeur j'emploierai pour aller
plus vite donc qu'est ce que c'est votre
approche intégrée entre la sécurité et
aussi quand même le secours en mer et
l'humanité en femme juste très
rapidement en juin 2001 il ya eu un
rapport de la cour européenne de la cour
des comptes européenne qui disait qu'il
y avait une magnifique a cité de frontex
mais due au fait que le système européen
de surveillance des frontières je crois
que ça s'appelle euro / mai je vous
préciserai tous à dysfonctionner ory
date de 2013 est pourquoi sa part évolué
ce que depuis ça va changer etc merci
merci marial est enfin catherine dumas
merci le président monsieur le directeur
merci de venir devant la représentation
nationale je voudrais juste alors donc
très brièvement et par rapport à la
question qui vient d'être fait revenir
en effet sur les frontières maritimes et
en effet le rôle de frontex depuis
l'extension de votre mission notamment
devenant l' agence européenne de garde
frontières et de gardes côtes savoir en
effet comment et avec qui vous lutter
contre le trafic illicite de drogue
notamment en méditerranée et plus en
plus important au niveau de son échelle
mais aussi de sa sophistication
merci
ces directeurs je vous demande de faire
dépenser un peu consiste parce que j'ai
encore cinq intervenants et une autre
audition donc merci merci monsieur le
président alors sur l'accord entre
l'union européenne et le royaume uni je
pense qu'en matière de gestion des
frontières il y as intérêt évidemment à
coopérer avec les avec les voisins
certainement que le les méchants sur
lesquelles il y aurait un intérêt sont
sondés champ migratoire mais aussi
peut-être les champs sécuritaire de
luttre contre contre toute forme de
criminalité
en ce qui concerne la méditerranée
et les leçons disons aux tirs et 2 de
certains opération quasi permanente
comme thémis en italie nous avons une
dalle aussi en espagne bon poséidon en
grèce je crois qu'on a on a amélioré
la lutte contre les trafiquants d'êtres
humains dont contre les passeurs on a pu
utiliser notre mandat sur la collecte
des données personnelles on est encore
en train de l'améliorer nous avons
renforcé la coopération opérationnelle
avec europol nous avons de façon
régulière dans le cas de la du
déploiement de missions de garde côtes
des contribuer à des saisies de drogue
par exemple 147 tonnes de drogue saisies
en 2000
19 qu'il ya dernières années on va dire
avant la pandémie bond avec des
statistiques un peu plus représentative
après la question du secours en mer elle
est évidemment dans d'abord c'est la
priorité quand il ya une détresse
maritime détresse en mer ça doit
évidemment appelé en temps réel un
secours en mer qui doit être déclenchée
et qui doit être effectif pour pouvoir
sauver des personnes parfois toute
minute perdue peut avoir des
conséquences dramatiques donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut avoir à la fois dans les
liaisons en temps réel être efficaces
mais après il faut éviter aussi
d'être un facteur encourageant les les
trafiquants on va dire les vendeurs
frauduleux de l'aide dorado qui font
croire à des migrants que c'est très
facile de traverser la méditerranée qui
leur font prendre des risques
considérables et donc je pense que sur
ce point là malheureusement trouvé
l'équilibré toujours compliqué il faut
agir dans l'urgence il faut toujours
évidemment et nous le faisons nous avons
grâce à notre drones permis de sauver
depuis le 1er juin 2021 nous avons
permis de sauver plus de dix mille
personnes qui autrement n'aurait
peut-être pas été détectés en
méditerranée centrale après la question
évidemment la libye n'est n'est pas
n'est pas le paradis sur terre
mais là je crois que ça pose des
questions à la communauté internationale
peut être à l'union européenne mais pas
seulement que fait-on pour faire en
sorte que les migrants qui se retrouvent
piégés en libye puisse être rapatrié
chez eux je sais qu'il ya des
initiatives qui existent
j'ai pu rencontrer moi même lorsque
j'étais
annie à meille quelques il ya trois ans
j'ai pu rencontrer des bénéficiaires
d'un programme de rapatriement et je
pense que c'est aussi comme ça en amont
parce qu'il ya combien de personnes qui
meurent dans le désert sur le continent
africain ça on ne le sait pas
malheureusement on sait combien il y à
peu près y ait de drame qui se joue en
méditerranée tous les jours dont le
sahara c'est un peu plus c'est un peu
plus discret mais c'est tout aussi
meurtriers en ce qui concerne les
éloignements bahia d éloignement qui
sont des éléments force et ça veut dire
par la contrainte juridique et
éventuellement par l' usage proportionné
de la force légitime et c'est pas un
éloignement musclée c'est simplement le
fait que si la personne qui fait l'objet
d'une décision d'éloignement si elle
coopère à son éloignement et bien le
recours à la contrainte physique n'est
pas n'est pas nécessaire si la personne
fait obstacle à l'exécution d'une
décision
si le cas en france c'est le cas dans
tous les états membres et nous
travaillons été et amant donc voilà le
retour sous contraintes existent il est
prévu il est encadré par le respect des
droits fondamentaux et par des moniteurs
des droits fondamentaux qui sont à bord
de nos avions en ce qui concerne l'amour
cour des comptes alors la cour des
comptes a rendu un rapport elle en a
rendu un autre aussi qu'ils trouvaient
que la politique de la commission en
matière d'accords de réadmission et est
inefficace et un autre qui trouvait
aussi qu'europol et inefficace en
matière de lutte contre la criminalité
donc voilà je pense qu'on est dans un
rôle c'est normal que les organismes
d'audit
face le guide de la performance sur
euros sur en particulier le point qui
est visé c'est que les états ne ne
contribue pas avec les informations
nécessaires je crois que ça pose la
question de la confidentialité des
données de la fiabilité et peut-être de
la même façon qu on avait vu que les
états hésitent parfois à demander la
présence de frontex sur le territoire
pour un certain nombre de raisons là les
états hésitent à mettre des informations
par rapport à la confidentialité des
informations donc je pense que c'est là
dessus qu'il faut travailler la clé pour
l'efficacité c'est la confiance avec les
états c'est pas en pointant les états en
disant que les états sont ceci ou cela
il faut être dans une relation de
confiance avec les états sinon les états
travail avant tout seul entre deux
façons intergouvernementales avec la
lutte contre le trafic de drogue avec
coopérons double les états riverains de
la méditerranée donc la france la
méditerranée pardon l'espagne beaucoup
de prise de drogue avec les espagnols et
avec les italiens un petit peu aussi du
côté du côté de la grèce et donc
globalement d une efficacité accrue
grâce notamment à la surveillance
aérienne
merci monsieur gates verra alors nous
prenons le dernier tiers des
intervenants hugh laurie merci président
mais ma question sur les moyens de
frontex a été posées et les réponses
apportées merci merci super avancé
nicole duranton
merci monsieur président donc monsieur
le directeur vous avez répondu donc à ma
question sur mayotte et j'en ai une
autre concernant donc le personnel vous
avez fait part de votre grande
préoccupation concernant le personnel de
l'agencé vous avez perdu effectivement
en 2010 900 postes vous nous avez dit
que vous aviez des problèmes de
recrutement au siège vous nous avez
parlé des rémunérations notamment celles
donc au siège à varsovie qui est 30% de
moins par rapport donc aux autres pays
de l'union européenne un rééquilibrage
concernant les rémunérations pour le
personnel est il prévu je remercie
merci nicolas joël guerriau mesdames
directeur il ya trois ans j'ai eu
l'honneur de vous accueillir au sein de
la commission que je préside à
l'assemblée parlementaire de l'otan pour
un débat passionnant et dont je n'aurais
juin oui que vous soyez enfin ici au
sénat est bon bien évidemment vous avez
tous soutient mes remerciements mais je
voudrais justement vous interroger sur
les liens de frontex avec le temps
puisque l'otan collaborent est-ce que
vous pouvez nous parler de votre regard
sur cette coopération un bilan vous n'en
aurez peut-être pas le temps bien
évidemment mais peut-être quelques
éléments que nous pourrions apporter au
débat puisque comme vous le savez nous
travaillons actuellement l'assemblée
parlementaire de l'otan a aidé dans la
dans le compte dans l'élaboration du
concept stratégique pour 2030 pour le
temps merci
dit joël guillaume gontard
oui merci monsieur le monsieur le
président messieurs le monsieur le
directeur je voulais revenir sur la
question de l'efficacité je pense que
c'est un sujet particulièrement
important quand vous aviez un budget 19
millions d'euros en 2006 et qu'on est à
460 millions je crois l'année dernière
donc avec une très grande augmentation
sans que l'agencé a prévu d'augmenter
ses écrits effectifs et dans le projet
pour arriver à 10000 en 2000 2027 donc
on voit que c'est quelque chose
d'important et ça a été rappelé sur le
rapport de la cour des comptes
européennes du 7 juin qui mettait à la
fois en doute l'efficacité de lagence du
point de vue financier mais aussi sur à
la fois le manque de contrôle et de
transparence et notamment au niveau des
des droits humains et de et de ce que
des agissement que peut avoir frontex et
dont je vous laisse avoir par rapport à
ces différentes alertes ce que vous
aviez prévu de mettre en place à la fois
sur phobos faute fonctionnement et sur
cette question de la transparence et
puis aussi sur l'analyse en matière
d'efficacité parce que c'est vrai qu'on
voit qu'ils allaient budget qui augmente
très fortement et qu'il est important
qu'on se pose cette cette question merci
si guillaume enfin pierre laurent
et merci monsieur le président monsieur
le directeur une remarque préalable
avant de poser ma question que les
choses soient claires je pense que la
politique migratoire européenne est dans
une impasse profonde je ne vois pas
comment on peut continuer à faire croire
aux européens que l'émission frontex
même en les renforçant son nature à
réguler le problème des migrations nous
ne traitons pas les causes
les guerres les le climat on voit les
résultats de la coop 26 par rapport au
sud les inégalités on le voit sur les
vaccins les trafics et on continue de
faire croire qu'en concentrant les
problèmes de migration aux frontières de
l'union européenne
nous allons être en renforçant les
moyens de répressif de frontex de
réguler ces problèmes ça me paraît
totalement illusoire d'autant que tous
les pays européens ferment leurs voies
légales de migration
ce qui ne peut qu'aggraver les problèmes
donc tout ça est propice ou
instrumentalisation politique je suis
frappé par la carte qui est affichée
depuis le début nous ne parlons que de
la biélorussie alors qu'on voit il
suffit de regarder la carte pour voir
que le problème biélorusse du point de
vue des migrations c'est un problème
géopolitique très important mais du
point de vue des mânes des migrations
n'est vraiment pas le coeur du problème
migratoire européen donc hors pourtant
on ne parle on ne parle que que de ça et
d'une certaine manière on se trouve dans
le paradoxe que la pologne qui était
infréquentable du point de vue que c'est
son rapport aux questions des droits
humains des nations il ya quelques mois
devient maintenant le rempart des
européens ce qui est un retournement de
valeur absolument incroyable j'en viens
mais question comment concrètement
s'effectue sur le terrain le traitement
de la question du droit d'asile parce
que on confond tout asile et migrations
donc comment feront frontex fait avec
cette question
du droit d'asile aux frontières comment
les gens peuvent ou non déposées et que
leur demande on voit bien que la
concentration aux frontières pose de ce
point de vue là d'énormes problèmes et
je ne vois pas bien comment nous
traitons cette question et
deuxième question c'est pour éclaircir
là dessus parce qu'on a entendu des
choses contradictoires tout cas moi j'ai
entendu des choses contradictoires
est-ce que l'union européenne finance
la construction de frontières physiques
barbelés murs aux frontières de l'est
européen étendre aux endroits et dans
quelle mesure frontex participe ou non à
ces financements ou qu'ils aient financé
ce qui a réellement un financement
européen de la construction de ces
centaines de kilomètres de murs et de
barbelés aux frontières de leur merci
merci pierre monsieur le directeur
dernière drôle de réponse merci monsieur
le président
alors rééquilibrage des rémunérations
non ce n'est pas à l'ordre du jour parce
que c'est tout le système de
rémunération des agents publics de
l'union européenne qui est en cause
c'est un système qui s'applique à
l'échelle de l'union européenne pour
toutes les agences de l'union européenne
et y compris les représentations de la
commission
les gens qui travaillent pour la
commission européenne à varsovie sont
eux aussi payer à 70% de ceux qu'ils
percevraient s'il était à bruxelles donc
je ne crois pas que ce soit à l'ordre du
jour il ya eu quelques tentatives sous
au moment de 2 de la proposition de la
commission de créer le corps européen
ça n'a pas pu aboutir parce qu'un
certain nombre d'états membres s'y sont
opposés qui sont d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
les états membres quasiment pas
représentés puisque ce sont les états
membres souvent à fort niveau de revenu
et à fort niveau de vie qui aujourd'hui
ne sont ne sont pas représentés par
leurs ressortissants dans le record
européen
en ce qui concerne l'otan et frontex
notre nouveau mandat adopté en 2019 à
une liste exhaustive et ferme et
d'organisations internationales avec
lesquels frontex peut conclure des
accords de coopération l'otan n'y
figurent pas donc stricto sensu ça veut
dire que nous n'avons pas le droit de
parler à l'otan en tout cas nous n'avons
pas le droit de coopérer
voilà ccc là c'est la situation en ce
qui concerne la transparence les droits
humains et l'efficacité alors d'abord
sur la transparence je voudrais dire que
nous avons tous les ans à peu près 300
demandes nous avons une augmentation du
nombre de dessus sur les 15 dernières
années du nombre de demandes d'accès ou
documents publics qui est une procédure
de l'administration européenne et je
crois que frontex est assez exemplaire
en la matière par le nombre de documents
qui sont transmis il est possible que
par exemple on puisse me demander les
documents préparatoires à ma visite en
france aujourd'hui et je serai obligé de
fournir nous avons régulièrement
le
médiateur de l'union européenne qui est
saisie sur des questions là et lorsque
nous avons émis des refus de fournir un
certain nombre d'informations
ça a été validé par le médiateur de
l'union européenne et même une décision
de cour de justice par exemple sur
révélé la position des vis et des des
navires de des opérations de frontex le
médiateur de l'union européenne et
ensuite ça a été confirmé par la cour de
justice de l'union européenne en
décembre 2019 a considéré qu'il y avait
un intérêt de sécurité publique à ne pas
diffuser exactement toutes ces
informations sur le reste nous avons sur
les droits fondamentaux les droits
humains nous avons un moniteur des
droits fondamentaux nous avons pour le
moment enfin me un officier des droits
fondamentaux qui encadrent
une vingtaine de moniteurs de droits
fondamentaux et bientôt 40 nous avons
une formation de tous les agents et
régulièrement un rafraîchissement en
droits humains
pour donner les connaissances notamment
par rapport au droit d'asile et à
l'accès à la protection internationale
nous avons je crois je n'ai jamais vu
nulle part autant de droits fondamentaux
et de droits humains que à frontex au
point que parfois les membres y compris
de l'agencé droits fondamentaux me
disent sous l'effet un peu d'une blague
en me disant nous sommes presque jaloux
parce que dans le mandat de frontex qui
lie à davantage le mot droits
fondamentaux que dans le mandat de
l'agencé des droits fondamentaux
nous avons pris néanmoins des mesures et
je me suis engagé en termes
d'amélioration de la remontée
d'informations opérationnelles
il y avait un certain nombre de systèmes
qui fonctionnait de manière
sous-optimale parce qu'ils avaient été
dimensionnées pour une époque où
l'agencé était minuscule et aujourd'hui
l' agence a beaucoup grandi je veux
prendre pour exemple les mécanismes de
d'incidents sérieux qui sont remontés
aujourd'hui de façon d'abord ça a été
simplifié pour qu'on comprenne
exactement quels sont les types
d'incidents qui doivent être remontés et
pour qu'on puisse de façon mieux cibler
immédiatement partager avec l'officier
des droits fondamentaux lorsqu'il ya une
suspicion de de violations des droits
des droits fondamentaux en ce qui
concerne l'efficacité
nous avons évidemment entamé un
processus de révision de notre
organisation intérieure de notre concept
opérationnel mais l'efficacité de
l'agencé du corps européen passe par la
bonne coopération avec les états membres
parce que
le mandat de 2016 déjà la ville avait
créé nous sommes membres de la garde
européenne des frontières et les
garde-côtes et donc c'est un concept qui
est en fait une réalité opérationnelle
celle agence frontex avec l'ensemble des
autorités nationales et il faut que nous
puissions avoir la confiance entre nous
pour pouvoir fonctionner collectivement
et être efficace de manière générale au
niveau de l'union européenne en ce qui
concerne le droit d'asile et la
protection internationale nos agents
déployés sont formés à reconnaître
encore en tout cas lorsqu'une personne
fait état d'un besoin de protection
internationale cette personne doit être
orienté vers les autorités en charge de
l'asile le rappelle que frontex n'est
pas en charge de l'asile mais le devoir
de tout agent de frontex et le devoir de
tout gardes-frontières c'est lorsqu'une
personne dit asile protection ou paraît
vulnérable ou victimes de quelque chose
qu'à ce moment là cette personne soit
orientée vers vers la protection est ce
que l'union européenne finance les
infrastructures les barrières à ma
connaissance non
ils ce sont des budgets nationaux et
frontex ne participe pas frontex n'a pas
comme mandat de construire des
infrastructures et les ou de lait ou de
les financer merci beaucoup monsieur le
président monsieur le directeur général
merci merci d'avoir répondu à l'ensemble
des questions ont été posées à la fois
je pense que ça a été rappelé par
plusieurs intervenants et le soutien à
notre commission dans une mission
extrêmement délicate compte tenu des
crises et la la la carte que nous avons
sous les cieux l'expriment bien je pense
que la voulait bien éclairé la
problématique du statut juridique parce
que vous êtes une agence ce n'est pas
une organisation interétatique donc ça
pose des difficultés est très très
simple à apercevoir puisque vous êtes
obligés d'appliquer le droit de chaque
pays ce qui à la fois ralenti la
procédure et vous et vos procédures
d'intervention
par ailleurs il nous apparaît sa jument
plus personnel que frontex arrivent à
l'âge de la maturité et peut-être
l'innocence des premières années ou
frontex n'était pas confronté à des
menaces hybride à des mouvements
migratoires aussi important que ce que
nous avons connu maintenant les temps
malheureusement changé
je pense qu'il faudra y compris au
niveau des autorités européennes de la
commission et notamment de la part de
certains commissaires européens
qu'ils aient une meilleure perception de
la réalité car au demeurant et au delà
des préoccupations humanitaires que nous
avons tous évidemment bien sûr mais il
faut bien voir aussi que nos opinions
publiques réclament la sécurité des
frontières et donc il faut que l'europe
soit à ce rendez vous en tous les cas
merci de cette communication qui nous
éclairent sur un sur un sujet très
important par dans les temps que nous
courons et j'allais dire comme écho à
votre intervention de le recevoir
maintenant nicolas de lacoste qui est le
nôtre ancien ambassadeur en biélorussie
et qui depuis vilnius
joue le rôle d'envoyé spécial pour la
biélorussie nous aurons quelques
éléments complémentaires à ce que vous
avez merci infiniment monsieur le
directeur
[Musique]